do you like as an observer ricky like do
you like
the sort of uh the downward spiral
that the collective has kind of been on
because for a second at the beginning of
this
for a moment everybody was together
for a moment everybody was like you know
what the whole world is dealing with
this look at the way italy is shut down
look at what's going on
we've all just got to come together but
now we've degenerated to the point where
you're either trying to call out
everybody for
anything that anybody has ever done or
you're getting into fist fights
over who's wearing masks and who's not
or whatever it is it's just it's reached
a boiling point
and it's kind of enjoyable to watch i i
i think it's like this i think it's as
simple as this whatever the issue
there are ten percent of the population
are [ __ ] stupid
for different reasons in different ways
and they take turns
it's not like there is a ten percent
that always get it wrong
right they're the same 10 they're not
but in
any situation right people saying
oh it should be the spirit of the blitz
when everyone pulled together no they
were [ __ ] idiots in the blitz
there were idiots who left the light on
in the blitz right
and they got they got beaten up right by
military police
right there's there's idiots all the
there was [ __ ] there was cavemen
right that would do something [ __ ]
stupid
right and the and and the other cave
remember you
[ __ ] idiot yeah you [ __ ]
you let them [ __ ] say the two tigers
just at the babies you
[ __ ] [ __ ] and he goes i was hot i
was it's hot
he was killed before he could pass on
his genetic material
right so um we we we come from a long
line
who of cave men who who didn't let the
saber-tooth tigers
eat their babies but we still have
we still have stupidity uh and i think
it's the same whenever they go
and also there's misinformation and
there's selfishness right
there's people breaking the rules we had
we had we had a guy here right
who was some uh a government aide who
put
put these things in you know locked down
in uh into um
uh operation and then he broke them
right he broke the he broke the rules
so everyone went we'll [ __ ] this well we
can break the rules in
now you've got like an adult i knew it
would happen and they did they went out
and said well if you can do it we can do
it right
the truth is they want you to do it
anyway and now they had an excuse
adults went okay he was wrong he's a
[ __ ] idiot
but two wrongs don't make a right why it
doesn't make any sense it's an excuse
to do it yeah yeah yeah yeah
so but it it a lot of it is just
misinformation selfishness conspiracy
theory
there's a whole load of people who think
it's a conspiracy theory for everything
from
it's the mobile phone networks to
a chinese laboratory to hillary
clinton trying to get trump out by
killing
a million people it's all these things
all these misinformation
and people know they're doing it someone
who starts this misinformation
knows it's not true right it's like it's
like
trolling now goes from it used to be
you know you know on twitter but now
governments use it governments use
trolling they know
they put out misinformation because they
know it panics people and you don't know
you know what the right thing is this
shouting
this shout in fake news it works you
know
and the problem is what really is
annoying
is that some news is still [ __ ] fake
and you want to go
why are you why are you playing into
their hands
why why not you know now's the time
where
you should you should you know the truth
shut out you should look at the truth
but when it's science it's a slam dunk
you know you've got anti-vaxxers well
what are they going to do when they
when we find a vaccine that works what
are they going to do
no
again i think like the flat earthers i
think half of those people are trolls
i think half the people who yeah
they don't [ __ ] believe that it's a
it's a badge
i'm the one i'm the one in the office
that says the earth's flat
well yeah what some people would rather
be famous for being a [ __ ] [ __ ]
but not famous at all and that's the
problem you're talking to two of them
that's the premise of our entire show
famous for being more honest